so you're Mary you said no girlfriend
how old is she she's 28 she she works in
production animation for uh for
animation company window box Penta buff
no blur blur how long have you guys been
together two years and two months
longest relationship yet you love her I
do love her that's amazing good
what's your language of love mine is
physical touch Oh
physical touch do you know all the
languages of love sweetie tell me what
the [ __ ] is the language I'll tell you
right now shut the [ __ ] up for a second
okay go ahead
let me say it again what the [ __ ] is the
language of love okay is this some hippy
[ __ ] I'm about to hear right now it
outlines five ways to express and
experience love I bet your money that my
language isn't in there okay I'll tell
you okay let's name it so rank on rank
okay some people this is how people
perceive love and sometimes okay the
stuff but love is perceived receiving
gifts number one quality time words of
affirmation but this is all one stop go
number one number two and then say
number one recipient you're saying it in
clumps I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about go ahead
number one receiving gifts that's one
way you receive love
number two is quality time number three
is words of affirmation
number four is acts of service or
devotion
number five is physical touch how do you
know that I love he's the number one
receiving gift oh now you know now you
know what I gave him I gave him so many
gifts and he just never even he's a gif
see what yeah what have you given me
lady
maybe I've given you everything
what gift as gift cans of spam that okay
damn it like I gave you an iPad do
different
nobody wants like very expensive things
and I try to stock up the money and I
buy them for you and I bought you one
very expensive thing what was it you
said I want the biggest beanbag because
our cat had piss on the other that was
and I got him a $600 beanbag and he like
was like okay cool like Heath and I so I
know it's not gifts I know that's not
how you perceive love be honest sir how
do you know I love you because I'll tell
you how I know you love me okay is
because I am such a difficult poisonous
sometimes kind of person to live with
and to deal with I look at my actions
and I go what kind of human being can
deal with this insanity and she's still
here devotion and that's why I know she
loves me then that's devotion that falls
under was that a number I didn't mean
it's an act of service devotion no you
didn't say devotion you said act of
service that's acts of service devotion
that's devotion is that's your language
that's my language of love is devotion
that's awesome okay that's like one of
those little little [ __ ] books that I
actually really do agree with yeah I get
help a lot actually
because she was words of affirmation and
I always complement her by calling her
ugly that's good David that's really
good really good you know like to get a
pen under write that write that down
call her ugly because I had an issue of
I could never compliment her the way she
wants to be complimented so it was a
matter of you can't do things the way
you want to be talked to you have to do
it the way they want to be talked to and
I had to learn that so you know I would
joke around like we would wake up in the
model sub ugly you know
and yeah I'm clearly joking but she
doesn't want to hear that [ __ ] so she
would just outright get mad at me I
never understood why oh yeah totally
[ __ ] love you I called you hideous I
just never understood and then when she
brought that book up my legacy just
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I tried it and it
[ __ ] worked I was a holy [ __ ] you do
all five no you know what I do the main
one she's all of them but she the main
thing is the words of information thing
like baby you look so good today yes
that you know where here is yesterday I
dressed up yesterday
and he was like where the [ __ ] are you
going and who you [ __ ] like because I
dress yes like you trying to leave me
[ __ ] that goes here is how dumb you are
sometimes where it's about affirmation
all that means you know if you could
just you know if interpret it the right
way is that you look good right yeah but
you're like [ __ ] yeah he's like where
are you going
and then he'll what did what did you say
yesterday he said why the [ __ ] are you
dressed up like that she gonna go see ya
who's calling you hot yeah yeah yeah and
he's like don't are you gonna [ __ ]
leave me you're gonna come on we're
gonna [ __ ] leave me huh that's what
she said well we were watching Westworld
last night
first you watch Westworld I should give
the basic premise it's um it's like a
theme park that you can travel to and
we're a bunch of ai's lived the horses
are AI snakes are AI the humans are a is
and you can pay to have whatever type of
experience you want to have there let's
say for instance you go then you're like
I just want to kill eight people you can
go and do that I just want to [ __ ]
hookers you can go and do that rape
treasure hunt you can do treasure hunts
you can have a whole storyline but you
pay for it this is a reality show it's
on HBO it's a show about this particular
theme park yeah and I said yesterday
that I would just want to pay a lot of
money to get like a [ __ ] train ran on
me by so many eyes like I want to get
gangbanged by like 20 a eyes it's like
[Laughter]
why did I say that though cuz you were
like you know what you're right I would
probably live in one of those [ __ ]
houses [ __ ] no no that's not what I said
and you know what I how dare you what I
said was you know what I probably won't
wouldn't do anything like that I don't
want to kill anybody or do anything like
that and then you said I have a train
run up on me or whatever gangbang
gangbanged and so then I'm like what
words of affirmation like number one
it's like you know if you have a little
bit of brain you would interpret that as
me telling me telling you I love you why
no training that's like me telling you
you're very attractive
that's not you [ __ ] yeah I wouldn't
want a what would you do what would you
do in a world like that where you could
pay money to essentially have whatever
alternate life you could have our
alternate fantasy so I could do anything
without repercussion yes it's a Western
world we'll keep that in mind so it's
everything's Western and theme easy you
probably do what Asians did back then go
the railroad have an opium den do
anything you want yeah you know I think
one of the things that I miss doing when
I was younger when you're younger you
could just uh you do things without
thinking about what will happen next and
I haven't hit somebody in a very long
time so I would probably beat the [ __ ]
out of somebody to my heart's content
mm-hmm to death or to just sort of like
just to get it out if they die they die
I mean they do the guts so what I'm
asking it right now is that you think
that whatever I did to an AI in that
world no matter what it is it's fine
yeah because the reason it's not fine is
because it looks so real so it's still
gonna affect your psyche even when you
go home I don't think you're able to
compartmentalize that experience from
your real life so if you see that if you
if you have a fantasy to stab somebody
22 times and you do that you see the
blood and the guts it's your brain and
your body is still experiencing it as if
it's something real because it is a
human face and everything so you're not
able to leave to go home and feel
nothing yeah so you have to be careful
about what experiences I was thinking
more of like I'm also creating the
scenario yeah like my mom is still gonna
poor making kimchi and somebody kicks
our kimchi table over yeah you know you
can do that you know pay for that
experience I wouldn't you know what I
would do I would do something that they
even never even thought somebody would
do glad like I would just I would just
walk around naked right okay
[Laughter]
I just want with this baby just his dick
just wrapped around my day I'd tape him
with like an electrical tape and have
just this baby okay he becomes the guy
you actually kill back to be is that
okay in that world I mean it's not even
a western-themed yeah they have babies
in it they have kids in it well ya know
what I would have a necklace of like
other like baby's dicks around my
necklace and I chopped them off don't
have a necklace of baby dicks baby on my
day and I were just walking around with
my god Bobby that's what you want to use
your money on no I'm just asking in the
movie in the show you have to be rich to
go oh yeah yeah you should watch the
show it's really good in fact there's an
actor in the first episode the guy that
plays the father what's his name Louie
Louie's Louis I followed him on Twitter
yesterday last night I'm gonna go be one
of the best actors I'd ever seen [ __ ]
good in the first episode it [ __ ]
lingers don't they oh that's good yeah
and he only has two thousand followers
on Twitter and I'm verified I know that
it popped up on his thing his phone and
he didn't follow me back
[Music]